[Music]
okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because i am joined by armani jackson
aka travis and amy coomb aka kennedy in
honor society which is out now i'm
paramount plus we're going to talk
spoilers here so make sure you watch the
film
first how you guys doing today
doing great how are you
doing great i'm so excited to talk to
you guys absolutely love this film and
amy i wanted to start with you playing
such a uptight character in kennedy were
you in that headspace all day or are you
tapping in and out of it
i definitely had to click in a little
bit more than maybe i've had to with
other characters in the past of just
being in my trailer and kind of
reminding myself like okay how would
kennedy be spending her time right now
she would probably be journaling and
planning exactly what she's going to do
and say and definitely just getting into
the voice and kind of talking in my
lower register
before we would do our takes people
probably thought i was like what is she
doing only walking around muttering to
herself but i think kennedy would have
done it too so yeah no you do a great
job and it's a great physical
performance too so props for that now
armani uh we get to see you sing a bit
here towards the end of the film
was that something in your comfort zone
to do it was that something kind of new
to you in your career interesting i
actually when i was younger i used to i
used to specifically get really really
nervous about singing in an acting world
like turn them down because i just i was
like i don't know i just don't like i'm
nervous to sing in front of people like
that and then i and then i started
making my own music and i started you
know being more comfortable with being a
song songwriter
and a song a song maker and so when i
got this role
i was like i think this is i think this
is going to be good for me because
it's it's a way to show you know some
singing in a movie without
without having to
without having to you know publish my my
being my own song too because i have
like my own vibe to my own music and
it's very
it's darker it has a more alternative
rock feel um and so it was really cool
to do more of a ballad
and to show it in a light um as amazing
as like the movie that we did
so yeah it was so much fun it was if if
the question is if it was out of my
comfort zone you know i thought it was
but sometimes i just tell myself
you just gotta do it you just gotta jump
into it and just do it and see what
happens and i found out in the end it
wasn't out of my comfort zone it was
actually perfectly and he was amazing
amazing
yes he killed it bravo and now funny i
forgot that i sung and then i watched it
last night and i was like wait i was
saying
i love that um
amy what was your favorite costume to
wear of kennedy's and were there any
maybe we didn't even get to see
oh
yes oh i wish we could have taken a
picture and done a whole scene with
everything i tried on our amazing
costume designer beverly had probably
like 30 looks lined up at some point um
oh i would say all of like the puffy
kind of victorian full gowns
were my absolute favorite i mean i'd
have my little like my little under like
my petticoat-ish kind of thing and i
would just prance around come out of my
trailer with my full
bustle
those were my fave
yeah i love that i love how abstract
they are really really just one of the
funniest things about the film um armani
what was your favorite scene to film
my favorite scene to film it was
honestly
rob well other than
other than what i think is travis's most
important scene
um which is i guess you said this is
this is a spoiler it's a spoiler
interview yeah oh yeah go for it
anything
i actually think it would be coming out
to my dad um
i think the payoff was really it was
done really well and i love how i love
how you do give that that fear that
natural fear of uh of coming out to your
parents you have that and you feel like
for a second it might go the way that a
lot of people feel like it's going to
and the reason why a lot of kids don't
come out i like how it gives you that
that fear for a second
and it pays off by showing you that it's
not always that way and sometimes
sometimes it's more simple than you
thought you kind of overthought it and
uh and it was it was gonna be okay from
the beginning so that was definitely my
favorite scene because i
i love i love
filming and being in the moment and
knowing in that moment that you can make
whatever choice you want and that choice
will be seen by a lot of people at some
point so it was cool
to be there filming that and think like
i'm gonna i'm gonna
be strategic with this and how i play it
and i'm i'm happy with the with how it
turned out
yeah it turned out great and it really
is a great moment and i love that travis
gets a nice little character arc
throughout this film like you said it
gets the payoff which is great so
everyone just keep watching honor
society it's on paramount plus now thank
you armani and amy for joining me today
and i hope to talk to you in the future
awesome
thanks so much